durch die hier seit zwei Uhr morgens
also ich bin total kaputt ehrlich gesagt
aber
ich muss einfach so machen also ich
warte jetzt seit vier Monate auf einen
Termin ich rechne auch damit dass ich
vielleicht bis 13 Uhr hier wartete Haut
zwei Bier sind da und meine Tochter die
hat schon über 100 Dinge geschrieben
niemand gibt's keine Antwort
wer auf einem Stuttgarter Amt etwas zu
erledigen hat sollte außer sein Papieren
Geduld mitbringen und Zeit Nerven
Stehvermögen Sitzfleisch und ein Stuhl
wie
allerui man braucht ein Urlaub auf jeden
Fall es macht mich wirklich kaputt also
das macht mich verrückt in 23 muss man
noch ein Termin per Post kriegen oder
der E-Mail oder er einfach vorbeikommen
in der baden-württembergischen
Landeshauptstadt sind solche Schlangen
nicht die Ausnahme sie sind die Regel
seit mehr als einem Jahr vor dem
Bürgerbüros und vor allem vor dem
Ausländeramt mitten im Stadtzentrum
dieses Chaos sieht man ja jeden Tag hier
ne
es ist echt unfassbar was hier passiert
wie gesagt die meisten kommen hier nicht
rein die müssen wieder einen Tag später
kommen da kommen die wieder nicht rein
da gibt es immer wieder Stress oder
Missverständnisse sehe ich nicht normal
Aufenthaltserlaubnisse
Arbeitsgenehmigung Migrantinnen und
Migranten brauchen diese Papiere
dringend ich muss meine Aufenthalt
verlängern und danach habe ich bin
letzte Woche hier gekommen ich habe drei
Stunden hier gewartet und die
Ausländerbehörde hat gesagt sie muss
nächste Woche wieder hier kommen und
jetzt hat im halb 3 Uhr bin ich hier
also heute habe ich frei genommen z.B
meine Tochter normalerweise muss ich
heute zur Arbeit gehen aber sie kann
nicht weil sie hat falsch esse
funktionsbescheinigung bekommen jetzt
müssen wir das heute ändern wenn es geht
sie bekommt keine Gehalt wer zahlt die
Miete die muss Miete für sie zahlen ist
diese Monat
wer es schafft eine Wartenummer zu
ergattern muss zwar weiterhin anstehen
aber wird zumindest eingelassen der Rest
hat Pech darf bis morgen wieder
versuchen und warum wird es immer
schlimmer immer voller in den Fluren
seit Kriegsbeginn sind tausende
ukrainischer geflüchtete nach Stuttgart
gekommen während der Pandemie blieben
Ämter geschlossen und vieles liegen das
Personal wird anspruchsvoller verlangt
mehr Homeoffice sie haben in Stuttgart
und in anderen Städten auch einen
eklatanten Fachkräftemangel in den
Ämtern Problem erkannt von Seiten der
Stadt Abhilfe schwierig
da sind wir selber nicht zufrieden damit
und das möchten wir auch gerne
verbessern weniger Papierkrieg
vielleicht
wir machen viele andere Dinge wie
beispielsweise eine verbesserte
Ausstattung der technischen Geräte und
anderes mehr was aber ebenfalls nicht
von heute auf morgen funktioniert die
Bürokratie zurückschrauben wieso geht
das nicht versuchen besser zu werden
aber auch natürlich die Regulierungswut
die Vorgaben die einfach gesetzlich da
sind die machen es für uns nicht
einfacher weil viele Dinge noch nicht
vollständig digital abgebildet werden
können wie wäre es mit Ausweise nach
Hause schicken statt abholen solche
Dinge sind angedacht aber in der
Umsetzung stockt irgendwie wir wissen
selbst nicht genau an was es hängt
Reisepässe Ausweise braucht
man braucht die Unterlagen Bild den
alten Reisepass wenn man eine hatte die
an die Einverständniserklärung von
meinem Mann brauche ich und mit allen
Unterlagen kommt man hierher und
beantragte und die Kinder müssen dabei
sein und das macht man jährlich nein ähm
der gilt sechs Jahre macht man jährlich
oh dann der alte 6 Jahre neue Regelung
mehr Arbeit fürs Personal mehr Stress
für die Eltern
kinderreisepässe müssen jährlich
verlängert werden weil sich die
Gesichter ändern
Gesetzgeber so festgelegt so machen wir
die Leute darauf Aufmerksamkeit sondern
Ausweis für die Kinder machen
nichts dafür
wütend ist diese Mutter nicht eher
fassungslos wie schlecht die Behörden in
Deutschland organisiert sind das sei
kein Stuttgart Problem ich habe in
Hamburg und Berlin gewohnt das genau
gleich
in Freiburg auch was mein freier Tag
heute der geht darauf den verbringe ich
jetzt mit den Kindern hier könnte ich
mir auch schon alles vorstellen so
gelassen wie sie bleiben nicht alle die
Mitarbeitenden müssen sich einiges
anhören kriegen den ganzen Frust ab
haben immer weniger Lust auf ihre Arbeit
suchen sich einen anderen Job die
Situation spitzt sich immer mehr zu
der Ton wird rauer und auch die
Beschwerden die auch bei mir ankommen
wie heute ist es schon so dass oft eben
warte Magen frühzeitig gesperrt werden
müssen dass natürlich auch manche
Bürgerbüros geschlossen sind und wenn
das dann noch kumuliert mit einem
Anliegen wie den berühmten
Kinderreisepässen die sie inzwischen
alle Jahre wiederholen müssen dann ist
es natürlich für die Familien für die
Betroffenen ist das ein hoher Aufwand
und stößt auf wenig Verständnis dass es
hier so wenig kundenfreundlich hier
Möglichkeiten gibt bei den Bürgerbüros
in Stuttgart sind derzeit 41 Stellen
unbesetzt das ist fast ein Viertel vor
einem Jahr da war es noch nicht ganz so
dramatisch Folge vier von 22 Bürgerbüros
sind inzwischen geschlossen dieses Jahr
seit 13 Monaten Stuttgart West der
dichtest besiedelte Stadtteil
Deutschlands
53.000 Einwohner auch wenn das Amt jetzt
bald wieder für einige Stunden öffnen
soll die missliche Situation wird
bestenfalls umverteilt dann fehlt das
Personal eben anderswo
eine neue App zeigt jetzt an wie lange
man wo warten muss die meisten Ämter rot
markiert also überlastet ein Besuch dort
sinnlos
einen Zweitwohnsitz in Stuttgart
anmelden das ist an diesem Tag die
Herausforderung für Christian Krummel
aus Niedersachsen es ist dem
schleierhaft wie schwerfällig diese
Verwaltung ist bei einem solch simplen
Vorgang es könnte tatsächlich viel
einfacher sein
sowas kann man wirklich digitalisieren
dazu braucht ihr keiner stundenlang
warten und Leute irgendwas jeden
veraltete
PC-Systeme eintragen das geht eigentlich
alles online und unsere Verwaltung sind
einfach 30 40 Jahre hinterher irgendwann
kommt der dran darf sein Anliegen
vortragen und seine persönlichen Angaben
machen
Papier
mit dem Papieren
Personalmangel meinte er den gäbe es in
vielen Branchen das ist für ihn einfach
kein ausschlaggebendes Argument nicht in
einer Landeshauptstadt nicht in
Deutschland
man kann das auch mit weniger Personal
schneller machen indem halt einiges
digitalisiert wir haben es einfach
verschlafen und in andere Länder guckt
nordische Länder da ist es
selbstverständlich
ist alles online
es macht keinen Spaß nicht links und
nicht rechts vom Tresen im Bürgerbüro
und Besserung ist erstmal nicht in Sicht
im Gegenteil die Digitalisierung sie
wird noch dauern die geflüchteten sie
werden weiterhin kommen und Bewerbung
für diese Jobs die bleiben wohl wahr
vielleicht hilft ja ab und zu was Süßes